are you doing today sir good how are you
I'm good it's nice to meet you nice to
meet you Tim man I look so I saw it
again on Friday night and I have to tell
you I liked it a lot more the second
time I think I really liked you did a
fantastic job with this so let's let me
just say that on camera and now look
Steve was so terrified about this
because because we've been friends and
you know like I feel the same thing if
you're gonna like read a script or
something that somebody is a friend
because when it's bad you got to tell
him and it's painful no I mean book so I
me word reading it you were thinking
like oh he's he's gonna [ __ ] it up no
I'm gonna have to tell oh no I'm gonna
have to tell you never here's what
audience I never thought you were gonna
[ __ ] it up I always thought you were
gonna deliver the goods and I think the
first time I saw it I was just like
because I'm just look I know you and
it's weird like I needed to see it again
- like really judge it without any sort
of without are you sitting there right
you know what I mean and like I'm like
oh [ __ ] this is really good like but
anyway I'm now wasted like I was like
I'll I said sorry yeah so I have
Michelle give you five more I don't
think that's true but let's hope for the
best
I do have a few questions so one of the
things that I was wondering watching it
the second time is did you guys ever
discuss having like characters sort of
relate to the audience that the time
travel aspect is like difficult because
I've always like I mean I think people
are gonna wonder you have one protector
you have one Terminator chasing her down
was there ever a discussion about saying
well the time-travel thing can only be
done like once a year or like some sort
of caveat to explain why it's one in one
you mean like why don't they just send
an army of terminator 5 yeah no I mean
we talk we talk about these things is
like the what if what if they sent five
and Sarah killed four of them and this
was the one that got away but it's one
of those things where you could go into
the what-if zone and never come out you
know what if they just put a nuclear
bomb inside the Terminator and he just
walks up next to Danny and boom and
triggers it wouldn't that be more
effective so it's kind of like it's so
you there I'd love to close all those
little potholes but you can't
you can't do it um if you do if you do
look at I mean Sarah does say and there
were two signals and she goes to Mexico
and if you look at that first scene
where the time bubble appears with grace
that's Sarah's car that almost runs into
it because Sarah was there and and the
implication is she was going to kill
grace she would have killed grace if she
had gotten the chance which i think is
pretty pretty rad and I actually didn't
notice that yeah I know nobody would cuz
it's you'd have to you know relive the
movie backwards but I like the idea that
and we even had it at some place grace
what it goes wait you were there because
you mean you were gonna kill me and
Sarah was like well maybe you know I you
know change the subject quickly and so
anyway there are lots of there's there's
so many ideas there that we could have
explored if we had more time
sure did you guys ever discuss Sarah
looking for calories well no she's dead
he's dead how could she in the with like
in the future oh I guess because it's a
different future yeah I just well I was
you don't like the alt timeline I don't
know it's not an all timeline one
timeline no no totally changed the past
yeah I'm wave moves forward I'm
wondering yet the Kyle Kyle never
existed he never existed no I'm thinking
about that yeah it's [ __ ] up you don't
want to think about time-travel that's
the that's the thing they could because
it's hard that's you got to distill it
down to something that you can like get
across in a soundbite and move on
you're know you're known for being
emotional and yeah it's true exactly was
there anything on separating or filming
that really got you that like made you
either tear up or came close to tearing
up I cry all the time
um the the most recent one was though
the the moment where see I get teared
I've just talked about it yeah weird she
finds young Grace and she says you know
what's your name grace the look on
antalya did it so well she played it so
well this look of stunned emotionally
overwhelmed silence was great and it
means nothing to younger age because she
doesn't know the [ __ ] this woman is but
it means a lot to Danny
because she's finally meeting
essentially who becomes her daughter you
know because they have this
mother-daughter relationship which makes
it really difficult when you have to
send your daughter back to die for you I
guess well I'll ask what I always ask
every filmmaker which is how long was
your first cut and compared to the
finished film and how many deleted
scenes did you have the first cut was 2
hours and 50 minutes 50 or 1550 got it
we got assembly was that an assembly cut
or that was the assembly cutted okay my
first director's cut was pretty much to
what it is right now
Oh got it okay yeah did you have a lot
of Deadpool is the same Deadpool's 106
minutes and the final one was 105 this
is within three or four minutes of my
director's cut did you have a lot of
deleted scenes where is that there's a
both there's a few deleted scenes and
then we actually trimmed down some beats
quite a bit too you know there was a
little bit more of the hanging Humvee
there was a little bit more of the
underwater fight there was a little bit
more the turbine there's a little bit
more than c5 and then I just condensed I
wish I could done that before I wasted
time shooting it but um you know can
only learn that in the editing room I
gotta go or they're gonna kill me
Oh calm I will see you later